peuple
[Musique]
diamant rsa en corner
même certains
st
les classes c'est la panique à madame
van ga ce qu'on peut soutenir c'est dans
cet outil
ouais
les je veux parler à monsieur wenger
c'est à quel sujet c'est personnel est
très important monsieur vente hier soir
par la viande en moins de deux heures il
est préoccupé écrivent à londres pour
demander un rendez mais c'est très
important pour l'instant ce qui est
important c'est une fois dehors du court
n'insistez pas monsieur qu'est ce qu'ils
voulaient on va pas se fier à l'autre
ça va faire deux
wesley
je vous en prie côté là je ne sais pas
aujourd'hui vous n'avez aucune chance
que je vous dis que je veux voir tout de
suite
l'effondrement des contenus d'hermance
c'est à cause de moi raymor jeu mais
j'ai déjà écrit avant le gers à ce sujet
si on ne fait pas très vite ils vont
descendre ma décembre connaisse mais
foutez nous la paix l'hôpital
psychiatrique c'est par ici
mais je me chauffe face merci si ce
n'est pas monsieur
[Musique]
que fais tu ici j'étais trop inquiète
papa il a fallu que je vienne où je t'en
prie la sphère ne peut réussir que si tu
te montant raisonnable pour moi tout va
mais c'est vrai oui mais j'ai encore
d'autres personnes à watch company donc
tout téléphonerait corps dès qu'il y
aura du nouveau
et maintenant fait quand il le faut
le made in attend
et ceci de bon fier car ce soigneusement
me montre à personne sauf si on te
remets un mot écrit mal mais pas et
surtout ne pose pas de questions
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
je
oui
[Applaudissements]
non
oh
bon
le commissaire la valise appartenant aux
morts
et quand même des dingues
[Musique]
j'allais un jour le patron m'attendre à
10 heures précises
monsieur thomas vient d'arriver deux
entartement et oui monsieur commissaire
je vous présente monsieur yann thomas le
commissaire principal javier est chargé
de la liaison avec nos services pour
toutes les opérations se déroulant sur
le territoire français policière ou non
chercheurs le cas particulier des
affaires dont s'occupe le pays ps nous
obligeant à employer des agents d'un
niveau scientifique très élevé
commissaire c'est parce qu'il est
convaincu des dangers effroyable que
pourraient faire courir à l'humanité
tout entière une science sans contrôle
que monsieur où il ya demain a accepté
de suspendre ses travaux à venir en aide
si en ce sens conscience n'est que ruine
de l'âme
ce pourrait être la devise de notre
maison regardez monsieur thomas
prenez non merci jamais avant les repas
c'est toujours aux flics de faire le
seul boulot l'année
c'est pour quoi faire
chercher
la lettre qui contenait ses prunes
appartenait à un homme dont savons rien
si ce n'est qu'il a été assassiné hier
matin devant la bourse de paris
la cause est noyau vraisemblablement
c'est ce qui s'appelle mourir pour des
prêts mais savez-vous exactement ce que
c'est thomas
en première analyse le fragment d'un
végétal de la famille des rosaceae a
failli stipulé de la base et à l'humble
qu'on veut lutter dans le bourg jean
promulgue harris autrement dit premier
tout à fait exact et thomas à ce détail
près que ce premier échappe à la
description classique est quelque chose
de lui
une dizaine d'hommes parmi les plus
puissants du monde ne dorment pas depuis
trois jours regardez pourquoi
et c'est un diamant son état frau prend
pas synthèse organométallique à partir
de substrats biologique végétaux activés
par des catalyseurs
cela signifie qu'en modifiant
artificiellement la composition des
molécules fondamental de certains
végétaux dicotylédones et le premier
appartient à cette catégorie on peut
fabriquer des diamants naturel l'anglais
perry avait raison on peut modifier les
enzymes d'un végétal de telle sorte
qu'ils fabriquent du diamant comme
l'huître fabrique sa perle oui seulement
malgré toutes les tentatives faites aux
filles tenteront de tomsk personne
n'avait jamais abouti et je veux savoir
quel groupe de savants a réussi ce tour
de force avec moi que les spéculateurs
se muer en ce moment à acheter sur le
marché à des prix incroyables des
diamants industriels équilibre du
système monétaire international et dans
ce moment si fragile qui ne résisterait
pas longtemps à l'effondrement des
valeurs foncières
ce serait la faillite des banques darwin
2 millions petit s'épargnant non merci
merci commissaire il faut patouiller
nourrir l'économie mondiale serait
perturbée pendant des années la
récession misère et chômage
psycho de suicide
voilà ce que promettent cette épreuve
notre mission consistera donc à les
rendre à leur vocation première
vous parlez trop souvent par énigmes
thomas quelle peut être la vocation des
prunes tous les enfants vous le diront
monsieur c'est la confiture
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en êtes vous mais chez thomas
g et questionner nos archives pour
savoir quels sont les savants
susceptibles de faire une découverte
celle ci
une reconnaissance orientations
scientifiques
dominante caractériel tels que
on vénalité tu t'es
puis alors comme un résultat nul
l'ordinateur s'est montré très discret
il a dénoncé personne
j'ai accordé une grande confiance aux
ordinateurs monsieur thomas bien forcés
même lorsqu'il vous donne temps
oui vous je vous ai toujours considéré
comme le meilleur de nos agents valeurs
personnelles
connaissances scientifiques
lucidité sprit décision courageuse
physique imagination bref
collaborateur idéal
justement vous demander une augmentation
malheureusement je me suis trompé
tiens tiens
notamment j'ai mis en fiches de
résultats de vos missions
analyser l'ordinateur je pourrais avoir
résolu nos problèmes oui tout c'est vrai
mais parfois le hasard vous a aidé
heureusement que serions nous sans le
hasard l'esprit scientifique ne saurait
s'accommoder du hasard monsieur thomas
c'est pourquoi j'ai demandé un autre
ordinateur de me désigner parmi notre
personnel
à collaborateurs que je vous adjoindre
est
insérez votre compte
directeur d'école
la personnalisation vivante et des
qualités qui vous font les fous ainsi
l'association de caractère fera monter
la dce de fiabilité à son réseau au
maximum pensez sérieusement que mon
complément idéal existe tout ça
mais comment tourner pour le voir je
m'appelle par parra merci
basse-bavière moiselle
[Musique]
autant vous dire de suite un modèle
andersen je ne travaillais seul plaise
ou non à l'ordinateur je suis un
individualiste ça tombe très bien moi
j'ai l'esprit d'équipé
parfait dans ce cas j'espère que vous
aurez à coeur de ne pas contrarier
c'est à dire
ayant l'intention de reprendre l'enquète
à sa source je me rends à paris
dommage prenez le prochain avion pour
londres
une chose qui je crois est au dessus de
mes forces séduire un homme d'âge mûr
pour pénétrer son intimité
évidemment
et dès qu'il s'agit t'il soeur cornelius
van geel autrement dit le roi du diamant
je ne manquerai pas
ban qui s'est le plus touché dans cette
affaire il a déjà perdu une fortune pour
soutenir les cours de plus l'homme aux
prunes cherchait désespérément à le
joindre avant d'être tué et vous voulez
savoir pourquoi
voilà
[Musique]
on va regarder à l'intérieur les élus
noté barbara a vendu pas mal
et
pas une étiquette de tayer pas la
moindre indication d'origine était déjà
une indication
l'homme vivait dans la clandestinité
sans doute mais dans ce domaine c'était
en amateur sans le savoir il a marqué sa
piste vous avez un avis examen de
certains joueurs montrent qu'une de ses
dents étaient en cours de traitement
l'analyse du pont-belge se situe la
dernière intervention du dentiste la
veille de sa mort de plus il portait un
bridge de pose récente il ya combien de
dentiste avarie beaucoup mais il ya
toutes les chances pour que l'inconnu se
soit fait sonner alors pourquoi doit on
a retrouvé ce coupon dans une pose de la
victime un aller retour paris dreux
alors le billet a été compostés
l'émission et porte la date du voyage
aller 7 juillet donc la veille de sa
mort ça veut dire le jour où le labo
situent les soins dentaires
l'inspecteur jean benghazi l'arrivée du
d'entrée alors j'aurai à il ya cette
dentiste druetta
aucun a reconnu la photo de la victime
était trop beau par contre y'a que trois
mécaniciens dentiste la ii a
formellement identifié le moulage du
bridge que j'avais apporté la photo le
la fiche du client porte le nom d'un
certain virgile floresco vf mais qui
dans le dentiste qui avait commandé le
travail l'un des sept auquel j'avais
rendu visite
le docteur sapin tiens c'est bizarre ça
convoqué moi ce docteur sa part savoir
s'il est souvent sujet à des troubles de
mémoire ou bien s'ils se fiche de nous
l'instant s'il vous plaît je ne suis
peut-être aussi conne amateur et je
m'étonne un peu différente à vous
proposer
cachez vous dansant parfaitement saine
s'agit probablement mon petit bieb's j'y
trouve erreur je vous inventez ma
clientèle peut-être pourriez-vous me
donner la vente pourquoi dans le
commerce
tous nos jours tout s'achète tout se
vend
voulez-vous que je vous montre mes
échantillons
[Musique]
c'est inutile j'ai mes fournisseurs
je ne suis pas pressé et je suis certain
qu'un jour nous travaillons en sang
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aussi posé ça sur le scénario
[Musique]
le madame je voudrais un numéro pour
londres s'il vous plaît avec un préavis
pour mademoiselle barbara anderson
[Applaudissements]
bonjour je suis barbares agira dans les
spéciales de préhistoire j'ai rendez
vous avec sur corner us à 16h je
racontais lucette en conférence
si vous voulez bien vous asseoir merci
mademoiselle zhivago d'arrivée
mademoiselle gérard loisel je suis à la
rue mackle le secrétaire personnel de
sarkominus peut-être plus je le remplace
et ses craquements
mais j'ai tout mon temps je peux
l'atteindre très bien merci
et puis ma dernière exploitation s'est
trouvé en sierra leone et vous m'avez
fait expulsé de ce pays mais bien monté
et confisqué et ce pour me dire cela que
vous avez demandé à me voir
non alors pourquoi c'est simple vous
demander 100 millions de livres
vous êtes fous l'ensemble des valeurs
boursières attaché au diamant est encore
baissé aujourd'hui de 14 points
ceci en mesure de précipiter ce
mouvement de le stopper
vous costa dans cette affaire je ne suis
comme employé mais le groupe que je
représente peu jeté sur le marché la
quantité de diamants nécessaire pour
vous ruiner ce record milius dans quel
but c'est clair vous faire chanter
jamais notre monopole n'a que trop duré
il est juste de vous mettre l'amande
mais nous ne voulons pas tuer la poule
aux oeufs d'or
c'est pourquoi je vous propose cet
arrangement
tout le monde y gagnera génie jamais
vous me connaissez costa si le bateau
doit couler tout le monde son bras
vous ne pouvez pas lutter avec vos armes
si vous tirez votre force du diamant eh
bien il n'y aura plus de diamants mais
des pierres sans valeur qu'on vendra la
tourner comme la bauxite ou le manganèse
comment les produire et vous par le même
procédé que vous amis à une échelle
industrielle jamais égalé
toute l'énergie que j'ai dépensé amaury
scheer costa je n'emploierai désormais à
me ruiner mais vous perdrez tout avec
moi
la science à des mystères ce record
milius je n'étais pas prêt de découvrir
notre procédé son inventeur est un
savant nommé virgie floresco mes
compliments
vous êtes bien informé et je sais aussi
qu'il est mort et que vous l'avez fait
assassiner du et son âme
mais avant de mourir il m'a fait
parvenir la description précise de son
procédé
c'est fou
le voici vous n'avez que la moitié du
document une autre est en sûreté
où ça ou ça vous ne le saurez pas je
vous accorde 5 secondes pour le tigre à
1 2 3
[Applaudissements]
n'attendez pas la personne chez le
président
et qu'on ne touche à rien que la police
puisse s'apercevoir que j'étais en état
de légitime défense
alors voulez vous me donnez la police
tout de suite à l'eau le superintendant
gipson ici mcfadden le secrétaire de
surf camp l'indus nous avons eu un
attentat à l'avant guerre oui oui un
mort non légitimes différences
merci en est le
vous permettez
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que vous faites là moi qui
êtes vous je suis journaliste
j'avais rendez vous avec sûr quand les
lieux sport à l'interview je m'appelle
mad'moizèle giraf où habitez-vous à
londres je vais vous demandant la presse
cheikh est forte quand un parc plein
téléphone 81 81 1
merci vous ne quittez pas londres la
demoiselle vous restez à notre
disposition
d'accord dites moi au sujet de costa
vous n'avez été de sa part l'objet
d'aucune tentative d'extorsion de fonds
non ce n'est pas pour me faire chanter
qu'il me menace est là c'est vous en
pays dont je pense qu'il n'avait qu'une
seule idée se venger autre chose sur
cornelius au cours des quelques paroles
que costa vous adresser à vendre ou de
masse et de son arme at il mentionné le
nom d'un certain flou ray 2d qui m'ont
dit d'où floresco virgile floresco avez
vous entendu ce nom adra bouche de costa
match avoue non monsieur non plus n'ont
jamais que stan m'a parlé de forêts se
peut-il qu'il était en contact avec
certains de vos collaborateurs phase
avec moi en tout cas ni avec moi
on sait cependant que florescu avait
cherché à vous voir à paris chez votre
agent de change de pl - enfin
superintendant que signifie cet
interrogatoire je ne suis pas
l'agresseur dans cette affaire la
victime
c'est exact c'est hors cornelius mais
comme vous porter beaucoup mieux que
l'assassin je me laisse aller à la
facilité
excusez moi je me permettrai de revenir
demain
est ce que vous voulez nous avons rendez
vous pour un interview sur cornelius je
suis mademoiselle girard de presse fars
décidément ces gens là ici sont
incroyables
certains élus le meilleur moyen de s'en
débarrasser c'est encore ouvert se voir
[Applaudissements]
merci merci
je vous en prie merci
et en moselle on peut dire que vous êtes
une journaliste qui a de la chance vous
êtes trouvé là au bon moment
asseyez vous voulez sans doute des
détails sur cette affaire se soit bref
il m'a attaqué je me suis défendu il est
mort c'est tout ce que je peux vous dire
c'est trop pardon cette histoire ne
m'intéresse pas je voudrais faire vivre
un électeur trois jours de la vie du roi
du diamant je ne comprends pas expliqué
vous incarnez lieu c'est très simple je
voudrais pouvoir vivre avec vous pendant
trois jours afin comme témoin discret
attentif
c'est absurde pourquoi devez avoir une
vie passionnante
écoutez moi mademoiselle trois jours
c'est pas long je me ferai tout petit
après tout pourquoi pas il est possible
que j'aille à paris ces jours-ci vous ma
compagne est formidable et revenez me
voir demain matin à 9h je vous donnerai
ma réponse merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'avais bien que servir un jour
dabo est pas un bruit bonjour docteur
sapin c'est gentil tout dire soigner ses
clients à domicile
j'aimerais te donne à voir quelques
explications
je crains que vous n'ayez pas le temps
de les entendre
sinon je crains que la passionne vous
aveugle cornelius pourquoi ne pas avoir
parlé au super intendant de la lettre
que vous avez envoyé floresco ce qu'il
ne faut pas confondre la police avec les
affaires gérald ni l'état avec la haute
banque privée et j'entends mener tout
seul mon combat contre la canaille
c'est extrêmement dangereux rassurez
vous je n'ai pas besoin de votre aide
bon que comptez vous faire pour trouver
avec elle si jamais il lui arrivait
quelque chose c est l autre moitié des
documents et vous pensez qu'elle se
rende compte de la valeur que représente
cette formule depuis qu'on a tué son
père
oui monsieur fait préparer la voiture
bien monsieur vous ne prenez pas l'avion
de nos jours dans l'avion on sait où
l'on s'embarque sait jamais très bien où
dans la série et puis une bombe y tient
trop facilement
en voiture avec mclaren et la petite
journaliste comme bouclier je serai plus
en sûreté
bien qu est ce que vous attendez pour la
porte
et qu'est ce qui se passe vous êtes
malade on ne savait plus où se trouve le
bouton d'ouverture
[Musique]
allez allez remonter en voiture faisant
juste vous êtes mort aux malades
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le papier oui et quand il ya des rues à
nadine floresco d'adressés est temps
d'aller elle fait vite et je suis votre
promet
[Musique]
madame madame s'il vous plaît parce que
c'est mademoiselle nadine florescu c'est
ici oui est ici nadine foresco oui c'est
moi c'est pareil
fermez là pour toi bien droit le père a
envoyé des documents vous mais moi aussi
tu sais on attend on les retrouvera bien
nous mêmes qui étaient mis à la porte
fenêtres à l'eau mademoiselle appelé la
gendarmerie tout de suite vite vite
[Musique]
c'est pour qui avait assassiné mon père
votre père a choisi son sort mme
beauchesne
j'espère que vous serez plus
intelligente que lui
et qu'est ce que vous voulez points
une chose
mieux coûter très cher
mais que votre père voulait vendre deux
fois je ne sais pas ce que vous voulez
dire
avec le temps vous ne tenez pas la
prendre et si le feu on vous aidera à
issy charlie 46 l'actuel majeur suel ici
on 3 sur 5 ans coordonnées cette envolée
des prix de 107 ans
jean-luc andoche en ayant deux
signal se déplacent nord-est et dans la
zone supérieure du triangle de repérage
bressan mers du monde sur l'avait pas
retenu par le 50 dos et en mini les
reçus est à fait continuer les
opérations de recherches terminées
en soi les signaux de plus en plus fort
la voiture doit être tout proche n'a pas
tardé à tomber dessus je l'espère pour
mademoiselle andersen
dans le cas contraire
ma ravissante collaboratrice n'aura pas
eu une longue carrière si j'avais su je
n'aurais pas laissé prendre ma place
juste un peu tard pour y penser elle
m'avait apporté une lettre de mon père
m'a demandé de faire exactement ce que
dirait le porter je n'entendais pas le
silence
appel général pour cela encore les
signaux charlie 41 à charlie 40 aussi
ses contacts perdu brusquement depuis
vingt secondes terminer ici charlie 46
que je confirme l'arrêt des signaux
terminé merci
c'est peut-être une panne de métro de
paris c'était arrivé je suis peut-être
parfois flic à l'ancienne mais la police
de papa parfois ça encore du bon la
routine mon vieux c'est ça que je vais
appliquer tout de suite c'est à dire je
vais faire coffrer le boucher entre
quatre murs éteindre à pamiers où je
trouve ça pas elle reste de la bande non
celle de non pas encore désolé mon vieux
chacun son métier
barbara était saoul maison c'est moi que
ça regarde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et bien mademoiselle floresco qui voulez
vous prévenir quoi et ça c'est quoi
et c'est un cadeau un cadeau vous
permettez pour le cadeau un cadeau de
qui un spécialiste en balises
électronique ou d'un inspecteur de
police
je comprends pas ce que vous voulez dire
tu ne comprends pas ce que nous voulons
dire à londres et dont la violence n'est
pas plus sûr moyen pour parvenir en
avions fait venir deux docteurs sapin
vous lui demandez d'apporter sa trousse
il comprendra ici à des grottes de club
spéléo va s'y entraîner le dimanche non
joubert les gens nous recherchons ne
sont pas associés selon la loi de 1901
alors y'a rien d'autre les allemands
avaient déjà fait le recensement des
abris naturels pendant la guerre pour le
stockage des veilleurs et db2 il va
barder à partir d'ici les américains
sont arrivés juste avant qu'ils aient
fini de construire la rampe de lancement
mais
il est temps 1 il avait déjà coulé les
tonnes de béton pour l'infrastructure
est en dessous je vous mets ton il
n'avait pas commencé à creuser des
hangars des ateliers bien sûr que si
mais donc je vous dise ne pouvais pas le
dire plus tard
[Musique]
oh
plus connaît bien les policiers sur
certains points tout se ressemble
par peur de laisser échapper les
coupables chalier va boucler tous
secteurs et ratisser le terrain
la suite est simple à prévoir barbara
doit servir d'otage
après floresco et soeurs cornelius il
est certain que vos adversaires
n'hésiteront pas la tuer
pour la sauver je dois moi aussi me
jeter dans la gueule du loup
on seul indice pour trouver le contact
et la camionnette que les complices du
docteur sa fin on l'utilisé pour me
filer nous sans doute est-ce le véhicule
qui sert à ravitailler le laboratoire
clandestin
si les liaisons régulières
je peux arriver dans la place avant que
chevalier ses hommes il est investi les
chances sont minces
j'ai pas le choix
oh
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
tél
on remercie des landes section coach
alors on la perd ensuite à venir manger
en mentionnant des changements on va
décharger tout de suite en virages en
épingle par mois
allez viens ddc le way lé choix
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
[Rires]
[Musique]
j'étais très imprudent moselle floresco
l'impact la police devant et monique
tous les clubs seule chance de salut
pour qui vous travaillez le désormais
nouveau campus
je ne sait presque rien après la mort de
menteur deux ans sans oublier de ses
hommes docteur s'apprend et cette femme
n'a dit lorsqu'on nadine floresco c'est
souvent rencontré floresco avec sa fille
cette femme n'est pas nadine florescu
mais qui est tous je m'appelle barbara
anderson et vous êtes de la police
rien ne peut vous sauver simone
collaboration
au pin la parole de ses filles
nous n'aimons pas la seule enfant
nous rappelons qu'en six personnes du
club
cette condition
tôt ou tard
dirai ce que j'ai
telle coopération
samedi
m
moi
ne vous en faites pas dans cinq minutes
elle va nous raconter sa vie alors une
dernière fois où se trouve la formule
que florès qu'on a envoyé à sa fille il
est d'ici si je lâche cette grenade il
ne restera pas grand chose dans votre
installation
qu'est ce que vous voulez vous proposer
un marché qui nous mettra tous d'accord
mademoiselle anderson contre les
documents de floresco donner l'air ou
les aurais quand mademoiselle anderson
sera ici près de moi je n'ai pas que je
manque de confiance aux marques et mai
[Musique]
ça va vous êtes libre allez-y
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes sorti
non
et
vivez vous
la ville
non
[Applaudissements]
bah
ce qui se passe j'ai peur je crois avoir
frappé une allumette cible fouiller les
galeries amené tout ce qui peut être
sauvé
sa lutte la perte des premiers à diamant
ça risque de leur amour fou on ne peut
même pas lui donner la plus belle pour
les faire pousser
que moi je les ramasse et à toutes et
qu'est-ce que vous avez l'intention de
faire de ces papiers on va les rendre à
la ligne hresko
n'en est pas question pas question
pourquoi ça lui appartient n'en veut
plus imaginez vous sans cette invention
sur le plan serait pas mort il adorait
son père lors de comprenait les diamants
industriels elle en a par dessus la tête
bah alors nous on va être riche
fermez les yeux et compter jusqu'à 5 1 2
4 5
[Applaudissements]
dionne pendant sa seconde vous aurait
été la femme la plus riche du monde
contre non parce qu'il y aura toujours
des hommes pour abuser de la science et
que notre rôle est de les en empêcher
vous avez décidé sans tous non si
c'était moi je vous aurais couverts de
bijoux et de diamants
[Applaudissements]
l'ordinateur
[Musique]
il
à
l'amérique fait un accueil triomphal aux
deux cosmonautes américain le colonel
bret et le majeur painter et au
radioastronomes francis leroy le premier
français à participer à un vol dans
l'espace
après avoir accompli le vol le plus long
plus de 27 jours sur orbite
francis leroy va maintenant rejoindre
son laboratoire de radioastronomie de
nançay pour tirer les conclusions de son
expérience pour participer à ces travaux
le colonel bret et le majeur painter
seront les invités de la recherche
spatiale
[Musique]
à
francis leroy atterrira demain soir à
orly et aura droit à quinze jours d'un
congé bien mérité
[Applaudissements]
voilà
la base de tous les gens qui étaient sur
les perturbations d'arada oui j'ai bien
dû rigoler moi j'ai passé mes quinze
jours en irlande la pêche au saumon et
qu'on n'avait même pas envoyer une carte
postale
vous avez passé de bonnes vacances en
vol
ça aurait pu envoyer une carte postale
dation distinguer enfin la formule à
voilà enfin ça y est rouge vous plaît
pendant votre absence j'ai été mis au
courant de faits inquiétants depuis une
dizaine de mois certains cosmonautes qui
reviennent soit de vols orbitaux soit de
trajectoire plus loin elle serait
victime lors de leur retour sur terre de
graves troubles psychiques pour ne pas
affoler l'opinion publique les deux
grands de l'exploration spatiale ont
fait volontairement
le black out sur cette affaire et les
incidents auxquels ces troubles ont
donné lieu ont été camouflés en fait
divers je suis arrivé à la conclusion
qu'il pourrait s'agir d'une maladie de
l'espace et si cette maladie était
contagieuse
voyez les conséquences et comment êtes
vous arrivé à cette conclusion
venez
[Musique]
reconnaissez monsieur alex et comique
obscures oui bonjour bonjour on a déjà
travaillé assez bien ensemble vous vous
en souvenez
oui bien sûr le voyage s'est donné
brisbane quelle aventure
bonjour bonjour au fait monsieur commis
coach qui soit le 23 novembre dernier à
son domicile de l'appeler vizcaya 14
blocs quatre appartements ces 8e étage
le colonel rostov de retour de son
fameux vol de longue durée a tué sa
femme anouchka 32 ans et ses deux filles
cyril et alexandra ainsi qu'un voisin
on a été obligés de l'abattre il s'agit
peut-être d'un drame passionnel moscou
consultés par mois au sujet de cette
affaire s'est contenté de répondre que
tous ses cosmonautes était bien en vie
elle me connaissait les russes enfin les
témoignages que j'ai pu recueillir
appuie fortement la thèse d'une crise de
démence brut alors jusqu'ici rostov
comme tous les hommes sélectionnés pour
les programmes spatiaux était
particulièrement bien équilibrée il par
ailleurs
vous savez ce qui est arrivé à francis
leroy oui
découvrant à sa famille assassinée par
un rôdeur du fou mais c'est la version
officielle
moi je pense qu'il est devenu fou avant
et que celui qui a tué sa femme et ses
deux enfants
mais vous en avez la preuve c'est vous
dieu qu'elle a trouvé peu facile donc
sommes pas de la police ah c'est votre
affaire
nous devons l'éviter communiquer notre
rapport aux puissances spatiales le plus
tôt possible
déjà les américains les russes en sont à
se demander s'ils ne sont pas victimes
d'un sabotage réciproque
vous savez où peut mener ce genre de
réflexion brett est en rtt compagnon de
laura sont également devenus fous je
vois vous voulez en venir ma loge et
andersen nombreux testeurs sont en
excellente santé tant mentale que
physique
mais rien ne prouve que le temps
d'évolution de cette maladie soit le
même d'un individu à l'autre et de plus
nous ne savons pas céder contagieuse
si les astronautes devaient nous ramener
de l'espace une sorte de névrose mentale
susceptible de contaminer la terre cela
pourrait amener la fin de l'humanité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
la réponse est là
or chez gustave marché avec un accent
aigu j'y viens
dites-leur bien ne pas se tromper dans
votre journal et accent aigu nous fait
bien de le préciser
vous savez où est ce que je peux vous
dire c'est pas grand chose mais les
leroy
c'était pas des gens avoir un coup de
bluff sur les rails on s'est défendu
jean pierre non je prends 10 ah non mais
quand il buvait un coup bas et plus et
chez deux nuls le ménage s'entendait
bien on savait ce qui se passe chez les
gens allez savoir mais moi ce que je
peux vous dire est pas c'est que le soir
temps en temps je les voyais il avait
l'air bien de quoi il faut des bras
dessus bras dessous et butane et la fifa
vous savez celle qui travaille sous la
tente relié à maintenant elle a
longtemps travaillé chez eux et les
appelait les amoureux je vais travailler
chérissent amoureuse
on en parlait avec chine c'est d'autant
plus triste
d'ailleurs n'y a pas de question s'il
n'avait pas aimé sa femme sa mort
n'aurait pas rendu fou et le roi avait
des ennemis dans la dans la région
pensez vous tout le monde les aimais
bien dans le village elle est même né
ici a dit le roi
ouais et c'est pas parce que maintenant
elle est mariée avec un cosmonaute les
agresseurs avaient pensé aux
envahisseurs
un cosmonaute pourrait très bien venir
fourrer son nez dans leur histoire à
sedan les envahisseurs est morte et a lu
ça dans dans tata doit parfaitement les
envahisseurs et vannes ont même parlé à
la tv les envahisseurs
votre sérieux voyons où en étions-nous a
dit moi depuis que mademoiselle
travaillé chez la nature hier madame de
gaulle avait plus personne pour l'aider
à son ménage
non je suis leur issue c'est moi qui
tient l'épicerie a permis qu'ils
aimeraient aller de temps en temps dans
le jardin non elle avait personne qui
avait mille importés qui pour gagner sa
vie donne un coup de main comme ça à
droite et à gauche quand il n'était pas
trop rond pour tenir sur ses jambes
c'est en plastique remarquer d'une
langue qu'il a son litre de rouge
il demande à rien à personne ouais à
clochettes on sait pas d'où ça vient
on sait pas où ça on sait pas ce que ça
pense
tenez moi eh ben la place des enquêteurs
j'aurais posé quelques questions au mime
il
oui
nous nous sommes déjà vu quelque part
qu'est ce que tu veux mais berger c'est
chez moi ici t'as pas le droit je sais
pas où tu sais rien alors alors du calme
je ne suis pas de la police mais je suis
têtu quand je veux savoir quelque chose
je le sais qu'est ce que tu veux savoir
ce que vous faisiez dans la carte des le
roi va j'avais soif
le roi c'était les potes je rendais des
petits services puis donné un coup à
boire par ci par là et quand il n'y a
personne à la maison vous servez tout
seul je faisais trop de mal madame leroy
elle m'avait demandé de mettre son vin
en bouteille et que le fond du tonneau
ce serait pour moi alors pourquoi vous
êtes voir fui civic aux mets toi ma
place après ce qui s'était passé
et puis tu étais peut-être un flic et
dites moi vous deviez avoir une drôle de
soif pour prendre ce genre de risque
vous savez quand on cherche toujours
l'assassin j'aurais bien qu'on le
retrouve jamais le pauvre pourquoi le
pauvre c'était aussi un pote la vie
parfaitement toute façon je ne sais rien
et dites moi monsieur mimile c'est très
intéressant ce que vous me dites à moi
j'ai rien dit ah pardon ou les de me
dire que vous connaissiez l'assassin
peut en rien du tout d'ailleurs faut le
laisser tranquille
vous aimiez bien madame leroy ça vous
gêne pas qu'il court toujours meurtrier
poil ça changera plus rien maintenant et
pour francis leroy puis justement faut
pas qu'ils le sachent
et puis j'en ai marre de tes questions
cité par la police
qu'est ce que tu viens pourrait donner
là dedans pas d'ailleurs personne ne l'a
vu si moi je vous ai vu tu irais dire
aux flics ça dépend ça dépend
ça dépend si vous me dites la vérité
et bien voilà
la mise en bouteille
c'était fini mais la clé de la petite
porte
j'avais gardé j'avais oublié de la
rendre j'étais venu d'honneur ce matin
là j'avais soif et je croyais personne
n'était encore réveillés et ont soudain
tu comprends les flics il m'aurait
demandé ce que je faisais là dans la
maison et pour quoi faire
pour dénoncer monsieur leroy le jour y
retrouve à sa tête il n'y a pas besoin
de savoir ça surtout que ce gars là il a
toujours été très chaud non merci
tu es un pote mais tu ne va rien leur
raconter aux flics
mais non voyons puisque je suis un pote
j'avais peur que vous deveniez pas c'est
déjà possesseur
[Applaudissements]
vous savez je prends un très gros risque
jusqu'à votre cause en vaut la peine
très bien je fais confiance je trouve
dans le couloir d'accord
calme je lui ai donné ces petits jouent
est très bien regarder
qu'est ce que vous faites là francis ce
qui doit être fait qu'est ce qui doit
être fait il faut tuer tous les enfants
et les cacher dans la terre ils vont
venir les prendre
elle est martyrisée pourquoi vont-ils
faire ça francis
parce que la matière organique et la
pourriture de la matière inerte
parce que la conscience c'est l'univers
à marée basse et l'ama l'univers à marée
haute
parce que les hommes sont des trous et
parce que la nature a horreur du vide
vous venez
dr le sénéchal croyez vous vraiment que
le meurtre de sa famille a constitué un
choc émotionnel suffisant pour mettre
leurs oeufs dans cet état que voulez
vous dire
ne serait ce pas plutôt le vol spatial
qui n'aurait pas supporté
il a été choisi parmi une centaine
d'autres justement pour son équilibre
mental et s'il avait ramené de cosma ces
maladies encore inconnue qui s'attaque
aux cellules cérébrales
cette hypothèse est terrifiante cela
permettrait de supposer que le roi était
fou avant le meurtre de sa famille et de
là à penser que mes remarques et cela
expliquerait bien des choses comme je
vous ai dit je n'ai pas accès au dossier
de leroy son cas est entre les mains du
docteur bras hier du centre des
recherches spatiales est docteur brière
est partie des recherches spatiales
bien sûr d'ailleurs c'est lui qui
pendant l'expédition d'apollo 27 étaient
chargés de surveiller le roi en
collaboration avec les médecins d'un
hasard bien entendu mais si sa folie il
avait vraiment aucun rapport avec le vol
spatial
vous croyez que le docteur brière se
serait occupé de lui sûrement pas ils
doivent certainement se poser les mêmes
questions que nous
allô bonjour baba il est irrécupérable
traiter uniquement par les médecins du
centre de recherche astronautique qui
écarte les autres médecins locaux ce qui
va dans la direction de votre hypothèse
il nous faut maintenant les
renseignements précis sur les
spécifications du vol de leroy et vous
les trouverez un institut d'études
biologiques pour la recherche spatiale
je rentre avec une couverture non alors
bonjour monsieur
de mon côté aussi confirmation vous avez
raison c'est le roi devenue fonds qui a
massacré sa famille thomas voyez
immédiatement breaker enter les deux
compagnons vol de leroy ils sont en
danger où ils sont dangereux entendent
bien compris
attention ici rb été numéro 1 à toute
formation technique
nous allons entrer en contact par relais
telle star avec vos l'efs quatre
satellites d'expérimentation ghanim elle
en trajectoire orbitale depuis 23 jours
nous allons procéder aux contrôles
biologiques du personnel en mission
contact allô allô ici mots allô allô ici
moreau commandant vol f4 galimède en
gravité zéro depuis 23 jours
ir bayreuth est numéro un je vous ai
capter d'incident à signaler depuis
notre dernier contact
non ça va à part quelques cas fait une
petite chute de tension il ya une heure
alors nous allons passer au contrôle
numéro 1 morrow à fabien ans maintenant
autour de calvé rp hôtel miroir y ait
été miroir calvet est trop fatigué pour
qu'on puisse procéder aux contrôles
ne pourrait-on pas remettre ceci aux
prochains contacts
allo relève gagnent email demande
refusée
nous devons tenir notre programme paraît
pour transmission à l'eau vol f daily
mail à léopold f ganymède oui j'écoute
l'état de calvet est sorti des normes de
sécurité veuillez lui injecter 5
centimètres cubes de transe calvin
additifs car je ne connais pas une
contre réaction
c'est un ordi mots tordus exulte
hockey volley hvga nîmes elle contrôle
biologique terminé reprendre en contact
avec vous dans six heures coupez les
contacts radio télé merci messieurs même
trois jours elle terminé tranquillisez
vous mademoiselle andersen
ils sont en vol dans une capsule
d'expérimentation qui n'est pas éloigné
de nous de plus de 15 mètres
mais les conditions de l'illusion
psychologique total sont nécessaires
pour faire des observations précises sur
leur métabolisme et vous ne craignez pas
d'accident il n'y a jamais eu d'accident
et ganymède et notre deuxième expérience
de ce genre
rascal mina a dit yves cas qu'est ce que
c'est je m'excuse ce n'est pas mon
domaine aux éditeurs s'il vous plaît la
transe calme et leur a dit hitchcock
qu'est ce que c'est je suis désolé
mademoiselle mais je ne suis pas
habilité à vous répondre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà aussi
j'en avais le déranger je cherche
messieurs brad hunter on m'a dit que je
pouvais les trouver ici
je suis désolé monsieur mais aujourd'hui
c'est d'ailleurs sur deux
comme sa poche peut les trouver
c'est la maison isolée juste à l'entrée
du village à gauche en un temps si cela
[Musique]
tu sais nous fallait bien finir la
manche
bravo cette année j'aimerais vous parler
en particulier
steve nom venant dans quelques minutes
oui d'accord
effectivement j'ai déjà entendu parler
de ce brouillage bbc l'organisation
internationale qui s'occupe de la
protection des inventions scientifiques
aussi et vous merci et que pouvons nous
faire pour vous me dire comment vous
allez comment nous allons mais très bien
merci
hors jeu d'enfant c'est gentil quand
même de vous inquiéter de la santé mais
vous n'avez quand même pas fait tout ce
voyage expérience si justement la merci
d'une moduler le méritons pas une telle
sollicitude pensez vous de la faire le
voit ce n'est pas une affaire
c'est un drame un drame horrible
j'espère qu'on va retrouver l'auteur de
ce massacre
c'est fait on la retrouve vraiment qui
est ce le roi lui même cette option
jamais le roi n'aurait pu nous en avons
la preuve
impossible franz était l'homme le plus
équilibré du monde d'avant ce vol oui
après aussi nous nous sommes revus
il était parfaitement reposé détendu
l'adour est sa femme et ses enfants
cette histoire ne tient pas debout mais
pourquoi vous nous raconter tout ça
lorsque vous étiez les compagnons de vol
de leroy et que vous pouvez nous aider
vous avez subi le même traitement
absorber la même nourriture
vous avez été exposé au même phénomène
je vois où vous voulez en venir
vous pensez que tôt ou tard il est
possible que nous soyons victimes des
mêmes troubles est impensable
nous nous portons très bien vous voyez
les premiers jours de son tour sur la
tire le roi aussi se portait très bien
disons qu'il a eu un pépin on a eu
beaucoup de chance de s'en sortir
d'ailleurs le docteur steve a marqué son
assistante peuvent vous le prouver qui
sont ces personnes les spécialistes de
la nasa chargé de notre surveillance
médicale
depuis quand depuis notre retour
quelle journée leucate de ce mois à
17h30 exactement cette précision vous
suffit parfaitement le droit de le roi a
eu lieu le 4 de ce mois à 8h15 du matin
et comme par hasard quelques heures
après on nous met sous surveillance
médicale
coïncidence vous avez entendu parler de
rostov
le cosmonaute soviétique bien sûr ces
véhicules est arrivé la même chose qu'à
le roi à cette différence près que son
histoire à lui a pu être étouffée par
les autorités
[Applaudissements]
monsieur yann thomas veuillez nous
suivre je vous prie n'avons pas eu le
plaisir d'être présenté je me suis à
partir nourricière a service des
contrôles de recherche de l'armée
je vous en félicite moi j'appartiens
obéit ps organisme supranational mon
statut étant celui des diplomates je ne
remets pas de police française mais le
sca compétences dans toutes les affaires
qui touchent la sécurité de l'état y
compris le contre-espionnage en cette
matière le statut de diplomate n'existe
pas nous sommes navrés monsieur mais
nous avons des ordres
excusez moi le temps de régler ce
malentendu julien
[Applaudissements]
fait rentrer désolé de ce retard
monsieur mais sans votre intervention
vous n'auriez pas encore le plaisir de
me voir je vous en prie thomas
essayez-vous aussi continuer
mademoiselle anderson dans certaines
manoeuvres critique ou délicates
les cosmonautes en mission doivent
pourvoir pour suivre la vitesse des
automatismes électronique de leur
appareillage
et c'est à cet effet que le service des
recherches a mis au point une drogue
capable de se réactiver les fonctions
cérébrales des pilotes
elle s'appelle la transe calmin addictif
car il est utilisé pour la première fois
pour le vol de brad hunter et le roi
mais dans le vol de rostov on a
également utilisé une nouvelle donne
pour la première fois il s'agit du mode
akale très intéressant quoi d'autre oh
rien de bien passionnant ce rostov
menait une vie tout à fait régulière son
sol robbie était bien banal la moto mais
il était mort du huit jours après son
retour de l'espace il participait déjà
un concours de vitesse qu'il a
d'ailleurs gagné à plus de 180 km à
l'air de moyenne
en dehors de ça rien à signaler
bref rien de bon on les couvre comme des
bêtes de concours
à première vue ils ont l'air en pleine
forme mais comme vous le savez on n'a
pas laissé le temps de poursuivre mes
investigations
il est pourtant essentiel de les
interroger à fond
mademoiselle andersen vous partez pour
danser mais ils vont se méfier
maintenant où on ne se méfie pas des
jolies filles
je sens que vous allez encore me
demander des choses impossibles
je vous demande seulement le faire la
connaissance de boiterie hunter de les
éloigner du docteur steve et de les
faire parler
[Musique]
pas mal alors 20 minutes 20 ça ira on va
vérifier le frein avant gauche puis des
portes un peu mais les médecins il
s'occupe l'économie le roi de coeur ian
thomas j'aimerais vous poser quelques
questions qui me permettrait peut-être
d'aider votre ami francis troy
j'ai déjà raconté tout ce que je mets
pour aider loi tout ce que vous voulez
mais ce que ça il faut que je file au
revoir au revoir
comment va-t-il leroy toujours la même
chose
c'est lamentable si vous l'aviez connu
avant quel type brillant une famille
tellement réunis je comprends que le roi
ait craqué pourtant d'après ce qu'on m'a
dit c'était un homme très équilibré il
était très sportif je crois nous sommes
tous ici plus ou moins quand on passe
ses journées dans un laboratoire il faut
un dérivatif physique la course par
exemple ils participent à des
compétitions de temps en temps il tenait
la dernière fois c'était juste avant son
départ pour cap kennedy
il est arrivé second et après son retour
pensiez vous voulez votre choses à faire
préparer ses rapports classés sous
observation
il devait être drôlement fatigue est
d'ailleurs la seule fois où il a clown
parce que l'accord est quand même juste
une fois des essais et comme je vous le
disais le devait être très fatigué parce
qu'il s'est plaint de maux de tête après
il était tout drôle
il a même trouvé ça plutôt marrant
voyager à 30 mille kilomètres à l'heure
dans l'espace sans le moindre bobo et se
trouver mal à 250 kilomètres à l'heure
c'était quand ces essais le 3 de ce mois
oui je me rappelle la date parce que le
lendemain c'était le drame
merci vous venez de me rendre un grand
service mais docteur voulu me poser des
questions ce n'est plus nécessaire merci
il y aller au bras de fer
[Musique]
je veux rendre service madame o non
merci nous
[Musique]
la peinture vous aider oui je sais parce
que là le carburateur qui bouchait mais
vous savez moi et la mécanique
on peut pas tout avoir c'est encore
molle jusqu'à nancy je dois y aller
cet avis km je peux vous montrer le
chemin c'est là que j'habite
ah oui alors vous connaissez peut-être m
e renaud notait renoncé je dois le voir
pour une question d'héritage
je connais personne dans le patelin je
fais un stage au laboratoire
radioastronomie voilà je crois que ça va
marcher maintenant
mais dites que vous n'êtes pas par
hasard jean break le cosmonaute
américain quoi servez-vous et parce que
je vous ai vu à la télévision quand vous
êtes prévenus de la lune c'était
formidable
et tous les journaux ont publié votre
photo je m'appelle barbara anderson
je suis ravi de vaud canal bavera et moi
donc revu d'un vol spatial rostov
dispute une course de moto2 jouera pas
dans une crise de folie furieuse et que
sa force et de vie
le roi dans les mêmes circonstances
effectué 17 voitures à 250 kilomètres
heure le lendemain il devient fou et ils
massacrent sa famille
oui j'aimerais que c'est troublant c'est
que ce pourrait être une coïncidence
oui une coïncidence curieuse et il ya
une autre résidence curieuse encore
c'est au cours des vols spéciaux en
question que russes et américains ont
utilisé pour la première fois des drogue
stimulante
les modèles cas de la transe cabine car
il est logique de penser que ces drogues
ne sont pas aussi innocent iii croit
même une hypothèse nous avons déjà qu'un
cerveau humain traité à la transe
kalinka se charge d'électricité statique
quand il est soumis aux bombardements
ionisants des rayons cosmiques pendant
plus de vingt-cinq jours à partir de ce
moment il suffit que les circuits
électriques du cerveau en question
soient fermés que soient mis à la masse
comme on dit pour que cette électricité
statique provoque des douleurs
insoutenables qui le conduisent à la
folie mais on les a mis à la masa le
retour de l'espace at-il ont touché le
sol et à ce moment là il s'est rien
passé
non parce que pour que ces circuits ce
faire il faudrait là nous entrons dans
le domaine de l'hypothèse faudrait par
exemple qu'il traverse le champ
magnétique terrestre à une certaine
vitesse
ouais mais ils ont pris l'avion il ne
s'est rien passé non plus vous savez
aussi bien que moi qu'en altitude de
champ magnétique terrestre perd de son
intensité qu'il devient négligeable
c'est au ras du sol qui est le plus
puissant je me résume 25 jours dans le
cosmos plus des effets ionisants sur un
cerveau traité à la transe calvin chaos
monacale plus une vitesse de 200 km
heure au sol dans le champ magnétique
terrestre et c'est la catastrophe
alors reste à prouver que mode à calais
trans calmin ce la même chose je
tâcherai de le prouver le plus
rapidement possible car si ma théorie
est exact brett evans auteur sont comme
deux bombes auquel il ne manque plus
comme détonateur que de traverser le
champ magnétique terrestre à une
certaine vitesse
au revoir monsieur
voulais essayer
oui
[Applaudissements]
pas comme ça vous mettez la main ici
vous soulevez le coup droit j'ai déjà
fait du tir à la foire du trône je mets
des bruits pas mal du tout vous savez je
parie que vous êtes une championne
d'accord pariant et si je gagne
si vous gagnez j'aurai tout les droits
d'accord ok c'est une bonne école
la foire du trône
ça tient toujours ce pari et comment
chapeau mais cette théorie d'absurde
votre histoire de vitesse et du domaine
des bandes dessinées pour adultes
attardés
d'ailleurs même sous une action violente
la transe calmin kahn ne peut
occasionner aucune lésion du cerveau
vous pensez bien que la nasa l'a
expérimenté et que nous mêmes nous
l'avons soumise à tous les examens
possibles avant de la présenter tous les
examens possibles oui il y avait aussi
des examens possibles
monsieur je vous garantis que la france
calme inc est un produit absolument
rigoureusement inoffensif
c'est sans doute ce que vous avez dit
aux russes aux russes oui quand vous
leur avez vendu la formule de la transe
karimine pour l avoir déjà vendu à la
nasa en exclusivité je ne comprends pas
ce que vous voulez dire le mot dhakal
vous connaissez ça suffit comme ça je
n'accepte pas des accusations pareil je
porterai plainte
alexis fait qu'est ce que ça veut dire
toujours debout
il fait perdre du temps monsieur je me
fous de ce que vous gagnez en trahissant
votre parole les deux hommes risquent de
mourir ou le devenir fou et de mettre la
vie d'autres personnes en danger
deux ans et ça qu'est ce que c'est lisez
vous même ça n'a aucun rapport
bien sûr puisque ces chiffres et vous
pensez tout n'aime pas que j'ignore que
je sois en langue est une des
principales l'officine de ventes
internationales clandestine
c'est à dire que c'est faux écoutez moi
bien je fais décoder votre
correspondance par nos spécialistes
j'entre en contact avec hong kong et
dans deux heures je sais toute la vérité
il sera peut-être trop tard alors alors
oui c'est exact c'est aussi vendu aux
russes
alexine ap le patron
demandez lui de prévenir immédiatement
la nasa trans calme inc a également
dhakal moi je file rejoindre brad hunter
vous permettez voyage côté droit
vous savez quel ses deux filles
non il fait partie du bsp ils sont
partis visiter le sang
comment c'est ça
toujours dans l'espace
petit sans angoisse les emplois sur les
apporteurs avec la capsule mai
ça ne poursuit pas même sur terre c
solitude de l'espace c'est tout le temps
on dîne ensemble ce soir
wen aux fiches à la tête
votre ange gardien
tevez man qui n'a pas d'air vas-y
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous sommes en brett hester
nous ne sommes pas là dr steve je crois
que vous avez déjà c'est peut-être une
question de vie ou de mort mademoiselle
on n'est pas reçu d'instructions de vos
supérieurs non ou le téléphone
oui c'est moi viennent pas au curry pour
rejoindre patate ne pouvions pas savoir
nous n'avons pas eu désordre
d'assistance il ya tout de suite
ils sont partis comme le centre spatial
ce qu'il veut c'est bien rattrapé au
bout du rouleau pas trop vite prévenez
la gendarmerie d'el harrach les routes
[Musique]
t
m
l'armée
non
à
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui vous arrive
ce n'est pas lui que vous avez fait
signe d'arrêter
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
ne tirez pas sur lui c'est tombé malade
viser les play
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
arrêté tiré hunter il vous sera fait
aucun mal
je suis prête aussi bien sûr bonjour ne
fait pas de complexe tous les deux
d'ailleurs la nasa ne vous en veux pas
au contraire installez-vous de monter
des visuels aux conclusions les jambes
au cou peut aider dans leur recherche
c'est avec beaucoup de fair fait qu'ils
ont communiqué le fruit de leur
expérience à la fois aux russes il ya
nous mêmes nous pouvons commencer
vaudoise elle voici un singe dans son
état normal mais auquel on a injecté une
dose de transe kalinka avec effet retard
pour qu'elles n'agissent que dans
l'espace laissé de mise sur orbite
réussie
voici le retour le singe à celui pendant
une heure les preuves de la vitesse aux
environs de 200 kilomètres à l'heure
voici le singe après l'expérience c'est
terrifiant chose que nous voyons dans
cette cage n'est pas un saint c'est
l'homme de demain si l'homme
d'aujourd'hui ne se montre pas plus
raisonnable
[Musique]